bonjour christian jacob bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes le président
du parti les républicains bonjour david
du cambre bonjour hedwige chevrillon on
va vous interrogez ensemble sur tout ce
qui fait l'actualité et la position des
républicains que vous incarnez mais
d'abord la sphère fillon l'ancien chef
du parquet national financier a dit
avoir subi des pressions elle a déclaré
dans la semaine avoir subi des pressions
de la part du parquet qui aurait pu
porter sur l'accélération du changement
de procédure pénale et donc la
possibilité ensuite d'une mise en examen
le choix éventuel du juge d'instruction
réputé de gauche et le tout à moins de
trois mois de la présidentielle alors
depuis elle est revenu sur cette
déclaration elle a affirmé qu'elle veut
être bien comprise en aucun cas dit-elle
monsieur fillon n'a été mis en examen à
la demande ou sous la pression du
pouvoir exécutif
cependant emmanuel macron a décidé de
saisir le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature pour lui demander je le
cite d'analyser si le parquet national
financier a pu exercer son activité en
toute sérénité et sans pression
comment vous jugez cette décision d'
emmanuel macron d'abord les faits sont
d'une extrême gravité
procureur national financier du parquet
national financier qui intervient sous
serment dans une commission enquête
parlementaire et qui avoue avoir subi
des pressions très fortes du parquet
général
avec des remontées d'informations des
demandes d'explications permanentes
on imagine que la procureure générale
faisait remonter au garde des sceaux
on peut aussi imaginer beaucoup de
choses ensuite c'est à dire qu'est ce
que ça s'arrêtait au garde des sceaux
jusqu'où ça remontait lequel garde des
sceaux a d'ailleurs été condamné pour
avoir levé le secret le secret
professionnel dans une des nombreuses
affaires qui concernaient monsieur
solaire bon tout cela veut dire que j'ai
bien entendu que la la procureure
revenir sur ses paroles
concrètement concrètement on a un
procureur qui dit qui a subi des
pressions et qui a travaillé sous
pression donc qui par ailleurs a
expliqué qu'elle avait en sa possession
les documents faisant état de ces
demandes d'explication incessantes à la
même été convoqué et on sait que c'est
suite à cela que qu'effectivement il ya
eu l'ouverture d'une procédure
judiciaire qui débouchent sur la mise en
examen quelques semaines à son rendez
vous voilà avec elle et ce à quelques
semaines avant le premier tour des
présidentielles d'occasion jamais vu si
on d'emmanuel macron de saisir le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature de
faire toute la lumière
ça vous dit c'est très bien vous a plu
oui bah je pense que de façon innée à
minima il n'y a pas possibilité de faire
autrement simplement ce que je souhaite
c'est que la commission d enquête
parlementaire puisse continuer à faire
son travail que ce ne soit pas un moyen
d'enterrer la commission enquête
parlementaire
il faut que tu mettes arrière pensée il
faut écouter ça va mieux en le disant il
faut s'assurer que la commission d'
enquête parlementaire bénéficie toujours
de tous les moyens pour continuer son
travail
est ce que vous pensez christian jacob
bonjourbonjour que jean jacques urvoas à
l'époque garde des sceaux que françois
hollande à l'époque président de la
république d'une manière ou d'une autre
vont devoir s'expliquer écoutez le garde
des sceaux a minima
je pense que la procureur général n'a
pas convoqué le parc national financier
enfin le procureur du parquet national
financier pour ses beaux yeux c'est si
elle était convoquée si on lui a
effectivement mis près une pression très
forte pour déboucher sur une mise en
examen parce que c'est quand même comme
ça les dates font que c'est à partir de
cette convocation qu'on débouche sur la
mise en examen de françois fillon
et ça à quelques semaines à quelques
jours de la du premier tour des
élections présidentielles ont précédé
les élections présidentielles pour vous
sont fausses et qu'il faut rester sur
l'effet sur les faits en droit ensuite
on verra les conséquences il ya peu mais
d'abord allant sur l'effet skis de
quelle nature ont été les pressions
est-ce qu'à la suite de ces pressions ça
occasionnait des diffusions
d'informations dans la presse acquis
remonter ces informations de quelle
nature il était donc il faut procéder
encore une fois endroit et par étapes
christian jacob un bourgeois est ce que
cela veut dire ma toute la sphère des
costumes les emplois controversée de
pénélope fillon est ce que tout ça
n'existe plus et un jugement donc il
doit être rendue et par le tribunal
correctionnel le 29 juin prochain
est ce que le jugement ma pour vous il
sera entachée de quelque chose moi ce
que je veux c'est la lumière sur la
procédure et sur les pressions auprès
d'un haut magistrat c'est extrêmement
grave
moi j'entends madame houlette qui
revient sur ses propos mais mais quand
on a le parcours qu'on a un magistrat de
haut niveau comme elle l'est lorsqu'elle
parle sous serment devant une commission
parlementaire
elle sait pertinemment ce qu'elle dit
lorsqu elles montrent des documents en
disant j'ai reçu la désinformation
elle sait ce qu'elle dit donc faisons la
lumière sur la procédure et après on
verra mais pour le moment
moi ce que je veux c'est d'abord avoir
la lumière sera dans dix jours
quand même s oui mais comme une menace
qui vient de se passer n'est pas anodin
ah c'est justement je ne pense jamais
ans
on a connu pareille situation le
candidat à l'époque parlait d'un cabinet
noir
il avait raison de son côté tout cela
sera démontré on va encore une fois ne
brûlons pas les étapes il vient de se
passer quelque chose d'extrêmement grave
les pressions étaient organisés c'est à
la suite de ces pressions encore une
fois le calendrier et là c'est à la
suite de la pression qu'il y à une mise
en examen et vous gardez pourquoi le
vent la girafe
pourquoi le procureur général exerce
cette pression lui même elle même en
l'occurrence a reçu pression de qui
vraisemblablement du garde des sceaux
est ce que le garde des sceaux qui par
ailleurs encore une fois a déjà été
condamné pour avoir diffusé des
informations et lever le secret
professionnel sur une affaire qui
concernait thierry solère avec tout cela
est ce que vous gardez confiance dans la
justice dans le rôle des magistrats va
écouter oui parce que là aussi ça ne
faut pas généraliser les choses et
encore une fois moi ce que je veux c'est
la lumière et la transparence et la
vérité et ça nous l'avons obtenu c'est
aussi l'occasion de rappeler le travail
est l'utilité de ces commissions d
enquête parlementaire
et quand on voyait ya quelques jours
encore le président de la république qui
cherche à étouffer les commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires en créant une
commission ad-hoc sur la sphère du duc
au vide
bon je pense que ça ramène quand même à
au rôle du parlement et rôle essentiel
du parlement donc surtout que cette
commission puisse continuer à travailler
que la commission continuait à
travailler et votre confiance pour
l'instant dans la justice en tout cas
dit dont elle est toujours là oui tout
un peu parlant de la question de la
sécurité ce sont les images de la
semaine et elles sont sur la question du
maintien de l'ordre dijon le week-end
dernier les manifestants les
manifestations des soignants qui ont
dégénéré en plein paris mardi
est ce qu'il ya un problème de maintien
de l'ordre dans ce pays qui s'est passé
est gravissime
on a vu
dans des villes à dijon on l'a vu à nice
est également des voyous qui défilent
dans les rues avec des armes lourdes qui
rafale dans les rues avec des
kalachnikov
c'est du jamais vu il ya un abandon de
la sécurité aujourd'hui dans notre pays
on voit bien que ce sujet n'a pas été
pris au sérieux ni par le président de
la république ni par le premier ministre
j'évite de parler de monsieur castaner
parce qu'on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il est complètement dépassé par
là par la situation
il existe même plus pour vous le citez a
coûté il ya une explosion de la violence
et de la délinquance
la france est le deuxième pays de
l'union pays de l'union européenne en
nombre de violences par par habitant le
deuxième pays
les violences les outrages sur force sur
forces de l'ordre policiers gendarmes et
aussi sur sapeurs pompiers c'est plus de
100 par jour c'est une augmentation de
20%
et puis également un ministère de la
justice qui part à vau l'eau
il ya un vrai sujet sur le régalien et
puis sur la prise en charge de la
sécurité intérieure c'est indiscutable
tout le monde vous le dira la réaction
des forces de police et de gendarmerie
qui n'était pas si commune à l'égard de
leurs ministres on peut pas trouver une
administration plus respectueuse de la
de la hiérarchie de son ministre là il
ya une vraie remise en cause il ya plus
de ministre de l'intérieur
justement au sujet de christophe
castaner qui répond à nos questions ce
matin dans le dans le parisien on a
découvert il y à peu qu'une qu'une note
de nos services de renseignement avait
prévenu cette note a été transmise le 12
juin avait prévenu d'une action possible
de la communauté tchétchène christophe
castaner dans nos colonnes du parisien
répond ce matin qu'il n'y a pas eu de
ratés que ce renseignement c'était un
parmi cent et que
voilà voilà ce qu'il répond ce matin
dans le parisien mais pas anticipé
suffisamment que pensez vous de cela
auparavant il ya quelques jours nous
expliquer que c'était absolument pas
prévisible n'y avait aucune information
qui pouvait laisser préjuger d'une telle
situation
c'est ce qu'on a entendu jusqu'à ce que
vous révéliez cette information jusque
là on nous disait n'y a pas de problème
on peut pas on pouvait pas le savoir on
pouvait pas le deviner mais mais il y à
l'abandon sur la sécurité ça s'est pas
fait du jour au lendemain ce qui vient
de se passer sur le dernier budget -6%
sur les besoins d'équipements sur les
forces de police et de gendarmerie
ça veut dire qu'on a une police et une
gendarmerie qui sont en voie de
paupérisation aujourd'hui une baisse de
6% des équipements seront le voit sur
les gilets pare-balles on le voit sur
les voitures qui ont parfois plus de 2
200 mille kilomètres sur l'équipement
informatique
tous les équipements on a lâché on a
lâché sur tout cela il ya un ministre de
l'intérieur qui ne s'est pas battu sur
son sur son budget un premier ministre
qui n'a pas rendu les arbitrages et
aujourd'hui on voit bien que sur le
régalien police et justice ont été
abandonnés à talons ans de même que sous
le gouvernement nique sous le
quinquennat nicolas sarkozy les
effectifs avaient été réduits les
effectifs avaient été chacun aborde sans
doute mais ça avait permis d'avoir plus
de policiers et plus de forces de
sécurité dans la rue c'est ça la réalité
avec des variations et laleu
la baisse du budget baisse de 6% 6 % sur
le budget de l'année dernière sur
l'équipement des forces de police et de
gendarmerie
alors une fois aller visiter les
commissariats pas vous y allez dans
votre travail j'y vais dans dans le lien
on voit bien dans quel état sont
beaucoup de nos commissariats et puis le
manque d'équipements de nos policiers et
nos gendarmes près christian jacob
c'était il ya quelques jours dans une
autre émission politique vous avez dit
il n'ya pas il n'y a aucune violence
policière est ce que ba aujourd'hui vous
maintenez cette déclaration à je la
maintiens parfaitement c'est
l'utilisation de la force qui est
proportionné aux violences que subissent
nos forces de police et de sécurité et
j'ai dit dans la même émission qu'il y
avait bien évidemment des bavures des
dérapages qui devait être condamné avec
la plus grande fermeté
il faut rassembler l'ensemble des propos
que j'ai tenu et je les maintiens
il n'y a pas de violences policières il
y a une réponse proportionnée d' usage
de la force à des violences que
subissent nos forces de sécurité mais il
faut pour autant qu'on donnait avec
condamné avec la plus grande fermeté et
tous les policiers vous le diront les
dérapages qu'il peut y avoir
l'enseignant noyer conçoit des vidéos
avaient d'autres images and then outre
effectivement les vidéos sur dijon c'est
cette aide soignante qui a été arrêté en
marge de la manifestation des soignants
mardi à paris alors deux images
l'image que l'on a d'abord découverte
qui est l'image d' elle-même tirée par
les cheveux par des policiers le visage
en sang et qui implore qu'on lui donne
son traitement contre l'asthme et puis
la même personne quelques minutes plus
tôt qui jetaient des projectiles sur les
policiers qui leur faisaient des doigts
d'honneur mais tout de même cette image
de l'arrestation quand vous voyez cette
femme qui est tirée par les cheveux
place des invalides
est ce que vous estimez que ce mode
d'arrestations est acceptable bien sûr
bien sûr que non mais le mode est ce que
le mode de violence et d'accepter
est ce qu'il ya dedans maintenant le
sait bien sûr mais il sait pas d oui
mais mais mais lorsque les forces de
police interviennent sont des moments où
ils sont caillassés
des policiers sont souvent gravement
blessé alors effectivement dans la
charge vous savez j'ai bon je suis un
ancien responsable syndical agricole
comme vous savez donc des manifestations
qui tourne mal je sais ce que c'est des
moments où vous avez des gens
parfaitement bien qu'ils sont de braves
gens mais qui dérape dans le mouvement
de foule
il n'empêche que la la police doit
intervenir ne doit pas être débordé s
mais ça vous ne pouvez pas on peut pas
généraliser parce qu'après ça les
policiers peuvent essayer effectivement
toujours se faire caillasser accepter
l'image de cette femme au fond elle dit
pas aussi quelque chose de l'état de
notre pays aujourd'hui c'est à dire elle
même elle vient à un moment j'ai pété un
câble de refuser j'ai travaillé des mois
elle fait partie de ceux qui avant même
la crise du coc vide travaillait déjà
énormément c'est des petits salaires
pour des heures supplémentaires énormes
est-ce que c'est pas aussi ça ni
malhonnête mais vous avez raison épuisé
qu'il ya un moment effectivement comme
élu mais il savait dans les mouvements
de foule encore une fois moi qui ai
organisé des dizaines pour pas dire
davantage de manifestations avec
certains effectivement il ya pu avoir
des échauffourées vous avez des pères ou
des mères de famille qui sont sérieux
qui sont qu'un vieux n'y a jamais eu de
problème particulier et qui à un moment
pris dans le mouvement de foule
parce qu'il ya un échange il ya des gaz
lacrymogènes avant etc pète les plombs
effectivement mais ce n'est aux demandes
aux forces de sécurité d'intervenir mais
sont ils sont dans leur rôle et on peut
pas en permanence expliqué que ça vient
des forces de sécurité est ce qui a
permis charmasson d'encadrement et les
policiers écoutez je pense que
contrairement quelques pays on a voulu
faire des comparaisons notamment avec
les états unis
on a une police et gendarmerie qui est
parfaitement formé avec un code
d'éthique avec une hiérarchie qui
fonctionne donc
donc moi je suis fier de nos forces de
police et sécurité souvenons nous qu'en
même pendant les attentats on a été
content de les trouver nos forces de
police et de sécurité pendant les
mouvements sociaux lorsqu'il faut
protéger nos voitures nos magasins nos
maisons
les badauds qui se promènent
heureusement qu'ils sont qu'ils sont là
et qu'ils interviennent donc on peut
vraiment être fiers d'eux circulez ya
rien à voir non voilà
ce n est pas ce que je dis mais ne
caricature est pas on peut pas
caricaturer vous dites y'a jamais
narrosse policière mais j'ai des maïs je
me dis qu'il ya l'utilisation de la mort
ce qui est proportionné aux agressions
aussi qu'il qu'il subit alors expliquer
comment comment on maintient l'ordre
comment on protège votre maison comment
on protège votre votre magasin comment
protège votre voiture comment on protège
votre vie alors qu'assange allan loeb
question parce que vous rappeliez tout à
l'heure l'importance des commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires leur utilité
publique et démocratique
olivier faur premiers secrétaires du
parti socialiste lui considère qu'il
faudrait qu'une commission d' enquête
justement sur la question des violences
policières et des violences policières y
êtes-vous favorable qui la propose
mais rien ne peut pas elle ne peut pas s
que tel il participa et wiba de fait
parce que oui on pas mais c'est quoi
cette omission est oui non je pense
qu'on peut pas la faire sur les
violences policières en tant que tel
c'est un tout il faut voir effectivement
comment usage de la force et est
proportionnel mais mais si vous voulez
ce qui me moi ce qui me fait réagir
c'est le procès qu'on est en train de
faire à nos portes de sécurité et et
dieu sait qu on en a besoin et qu'on
était content de les trouver à de
nombreuses reprises et objectivement
quand on se compare à beaucoup d'autres
prix on peut être fiers de la formation
nos policiers et nos gendarmes
donc faisons attention là aussi aux
amalgames
encore une fois il peut y avoir des
dérapages individuels et il devrait être
sanctionnée avec la plus grande fermeté
je l' ai toujours dit et les et toutes
les forces de police et de sécurité vous
le diront mais attention le moment david
le sujet ces derniers jours
au delà des violences policières
supposer c'est le racisme
il ya eu dvd des échanges réseaux
sociaux d'autres policiers il ya sept ce
soupçon il ya eu ce débat qui est née
sur certaines statues qu'il faudrait
déboulonner emmanuel macron à trancher
le débat
il a dit pas question de déboulonner la
moindre statut mais tout de même
question le colonialisme l' esclavage
sont des mémoires qui génère de la
souffrance pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens est ce qu'il faut s'en
occuper
est ce que il y as pour vous
responsables politiques patrons de l ère
des propositions à émettre pour que
peut-être notre société se pose des
questions et fasse ce travail mémoriel
écoutez je pense qu'il a il a déjà été
il a déjà été fait je crois j'ai
toujours été très réservée sur les sons
les lois mémorielles
ça relève de l'histoire c'est le travail
dès le travail des historiens
notre histoire est pas celle des états
unis oui quand et des comparaisons sur
la police
on a une police en france qui correspond
à notre société
elle est à l'image de la société
française notre les diverses boutlélis
oui j'avais la même banque verte lui
c'est finalement que la classe politique
oui l'occurrence oui en l'occurrence oui
donc pour vous en tout cas il faut pas
rouvrir cette question s est jamais
mention des jeux c'est sûr et plus
résidant mettre en question la ligne du
président là dessus tellement on
aimerait la colère parce que par exemple
quand on est la mienne ou un voleur
canton mais on fait entrer simone veil
au panthéon
ce sont des travail mémoriel qui ont
lieu avec nos jeunes avec les
professeurs sur esclavage sur le
colonialisme sk pas une initiative à
prendre on croit que on croit comprendre
que peut-être sur un grand événement
organisé autour des accords d'evian
prochainement vous ne trouvez pas que il
ya un boulot à accomplir avec nos
enfants avec nos jeunes mais c'est le
travail des historiens
ça n'est pas là la puissance publique
n'a rien à voir là n'est pas la classe
politique d'aller revisiter l'histoire
bon cette phrase elle est très claire
david du corps et dix surveillants et
surtout vous christian jacob vous restez
avec nous dans un instant on reviendra
notamment sur la question de l'écologie
puisque la convention citoyenne pour le
climat demande un référendum
on verra si vous et l'opposition vous y
est favorable a tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
on poursuit avec vous christian jacob se
bfm politique une question d'abord sur
l'écologie la convention citoyenne pour
le climat qui regroupe donc 150 citoyens
tirés au sort remet aujourd'hui ses
propositions 149 proposition fait qu'on
en prenne quelques unes et que vous
disiez si vous êtes pour ou contre et
notamment la plus emblématique limiter
la vitesse à 110 km h sur les autoroutes
pour ou contre
je suis je suis contre je pense que les
autoroutes ont été faits justement pour
qu'on puisse rouler en sécurité
et si on baisse systématiquement la
vitesse sur les autoroutes on va
retrouver des voitures sur le réseau
secondaire qui est beaucoup moins secure
que ne le sont les autoroutes et
l'extension des aéroports qui serait est
interdite
est ce que ça vous êtes pour ou contre
non je jules femmes je pense que le
trafic aérien doit doit s'adapter là
aussi à la demande
ce n'est pas un dogme de dire il faut
agrandir les aéroports mais si le trafic
aérien le nécessitent pourquoi ne pas le
faire
on peut aussi avoir des carburants qui
seront moins polluants on peut aussi
avoir des moteurs d'avion qui consomment
qui consomment moins il ya beaucoup de
choses à porter mais mais faisons
attention de ne de ne pas contrainte de
ne pas limiter les déplacements
on a besoin de se déplacer notre
économie a besoin aussi que les gens
bougent pour que l'économie fonctionne
en faisant attention à de nobles n'ont
pas de dogme du pragmatisme agissante
les saint-jacques à bastia par là il ya
150 propositions j'ai envie de dire il
ya 150 interdiction est ce qu'on est
toujours dans l'écologie punitive ce
qu'a pris notre manière de parler de
l'écologie
bien sûr que si qui est notre manière
alors on j'ai pas vu les 150
propositions mais disons celle qui en
ressortent moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
quand on est effectivement dans la
contrainte et dans l'écologie punitive
moi je crois qu'il faut absolument
réconcilier écologie et économie et je
suis très attaché aux principes du
développement durable développement
durable c'est un trépied le trépied
c'est de dire d'abord une économie une
entreprise quelle qu'elle soit et doit
d'abord avoir une rentabilité économique
si elle n'a pas de rentabilité
économique et ne tient pas dans la durée
ne fait pas tenir une entreprise ou un
projet à coup de subventions
ensuite ça doit être facteur de progrès
social
c'est à dire que celui ceux ou celles
qui travaillent doivent doivent
bénéficier des des recettes
et puis de justement de la rentabilité
de cette entreprise sinon ça ne sert à
ça ne sert à rien et troisième élément
préserver notre environnement parce que
c'est ça qui assure la pérennité et donc
si vous prenez une des logiques par
rapport aux autres vous en vous isoler
un des trois pieds ça ne marche pas le
libéralisme pour le libéralisme le
profit pour le profit moi ça m'intéresse
pas du social pour du social si on ne
gagne pas d'argent avant peut pas faire
de social et de l'environnement pour
l'environnement si ça ne sert pas ceux
qui travaillent ce n'est pas intéressant
donc c'est un tout or là on part
effectivement dans une logique de
décroissance de contraintes de punition
l'écologie ça doit pas être la punition
ça doit être justement l'art de pouvoir
vivre dans de bonnes conditions
christian jacob est une question à l'élu
aux parlementaires cette convention
citoyenne avec ces hommes et ces femmes
tiré au sort qui était volontaire tout
de même on le précise est ce qu'elle est
légitime elle n'est pas illégitime
ensuite le pouvoir de décision nous
sommes dans une démocratie
représentative
c'est le sait le rôle de ce le rôle du
parlement le parlement peut être
éclairée par le réseau associatif par un
certain nombre de pouvoirs ou de
contre-pouvoir organisé mais maintenant
ils maintenant elle est liée à un autre
emmanuel mâcon c'est lié les mains il a
dit ses propositions là j'en tiendrai
compte soit devant le parlement soit par
référendum
nous verrons un credo des promesses vous
savez ces macro à chaque fois qu'il ya
un problème et créer une commission une
fois que la commission est terminée il
annonce un grand discours et après le
grand discours il se passe plus rien et
on redémarre sur un autre sujet et à
chaque fois d'ailleurs qu'il prononce un
discours les persuader de faire une
réforme
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui des
réformes y en a pas eu des discours
beaucoup mais des réformes y en a pas eu
il ya eu des rues savoir si on va y
revenir sur un exemple si on a plusieurs
films revient d'ailleurs sur la table
après cette folle période de parenthèse
sur le référendum le
l'idée de mettre en place un référendum
peut-être même rapidement à la suite des
propositions de la convention citoyenne
est ce que vous y êtes favorable est ce
que vous seriez hockey bref l'heure odom
pourquoi sur quoi elle est la question
l'une des questions qui commencent à
être envisagée mais évidemment on n'a
pas encore la question bien entendu mais
l'une des questions qui en tout cas
proposé par ses membres de cette
convention se serait l'inscription de la
préservation de l'environnement dans la
constitution ainsi que le crime déco
side c'est à dire le crime contre la
planète contre l'environnement
je pense qu'il faut fiche la paix à la
constitution c'est plutôt mon point de
vue sur le sujet pourquoi en revanche il
y à des mesures à prendre en matière
d'environnement c'est une évidence
voyez par exemple sur le sujet de
l'énergie qui est un sujet extrêmement
important
je pense qu'on aurait intérêt
aujourd'hui à lancer un grand plan
d'économies d'énergie d'isolation des
bâtiments et des logements ce qui
permettrait à la fois de baisser la
consommation d'énergie donc moins
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
baisser les dépenses des ménages et en
même temps de relancer l'activité dans
le bâtiment
c'est le gouvernement non c'est presque
fait mais je m'en suis pas rendu compte
julien de normandie travaille en ce
moment les ballons ils travaillent
espace parents je suis fière
ben oui mais depuis trois ans n'ont rien
vu j'ai bien compris que à partir là
dans les dix jours qui viennent on l'est
à voir toutes les réformes dire y'a rien
fait pendant trois ans mais pendant 18
mois ça va être génial on va boire y
arrive le moment pour concrètement dans
des sur ce sujet concrètement ya rien eu
on vous sent particulièrement ironique
mais justement sur cette crise enrico
concret en l'occurrence pas ironique
concret il n'y a pas eu avec moi
concrets comme ça économiquement la
crise qui vient donc après la crise
sanitaire c'est sans doute une crise
économique et de vie chevrier avec des
tous les clignotants qui sont au rouge
sombre et est ce que l'art donc demain
les cinémas partout le cinéma certains
sports sont autorisés on est dans un
monde rentre presque dans un
déconfinement quasi totale est ce qu il
était temps à vos yeux christian jacob
oui parce que c'est trop prématuré non
non je pense que c'est une bonne
décision qui a été prise
il faut dire que la france s'en
remettent à fonctionner que notre
économie redémarre et ça va être
catastrophique vous qui suivez très bien
de très près les sujets économiques
voyez bien qu'il ya un moment il faut
quand même que tout le monde se remette
au travail et que ça et que ça redémarre
nord je trouve que c'était une bonne
décision
est-ce qu'il faut inciter justement les
français être à à se remettre au travail
à travailler plus
est ce que c'est pour vous quelque chose
d'important basse essentiel est
essentiel c'est essentiel que la france
se remettent se remettent au travail
vous savez il ya un moment il faut payer
la note donc on peut rêver de
subventions d'être dans tous les sens
mais mais mais qui les payent et donc si
on veut être capable de faire face à ses
dettes
c'est d'abord que se remettent au
travail ils se remettent au travail le
plus rapidement possible dans le respect
des règles des règles sanitaires mais
c'est pour ça que je trouve qu'il était
temps de des confiné l'ailé des déficits
sont en train d'exploser la dette et de
se remettre au boulot est ce que
christian jacob vous pensez que nos
concitoyens peuvent être tranquilles sur
l'idée que les impôts n'augmenteront pas
main mais je pense qu'on a un tel niveau
de prélèvements obligatoires
ce serait de la folie que d'augmenter
les impôts aujourd'hui on détient le
record européen des prélèvements
obligatoires n'a passé la barre des 48 %
on a par ailleurs le pire déficit public
de la zone euro le pire déficit
commercial de l'union européenne
on a dépassé avant le coc vide un taux
d'endettement jamais atteint les 100%
nous avons le 25e taux de croissance sur
donc il est temps que l'économie se
remette en place et ça n'est pas en
chargeant avec des impôts et des taxes
mais qu'on va faire des économies là
vous le disiez à un moment il va quand
même falloir passer à la caisse il va
falloir payer la note donc ok pas les
impôts travailler davantage concrètement
ça veut dire pas de payer davantage
est ce que vous êtes favorable à ce que
les ans les parents les français est ce
que vous êtes favorable à ce que les
français renoncent éventuellement à un
jour de congé est ce qu'il faut à un
moment que concrètement il ya un jour de
congé qui dit qui saute
est ce qu'il faut même
accepter al'inverse les baisses de
salaires pour que les entreprises
maintiennent des emplois est ce qu'il
faut accepter ce genre d'organisation au
moins temporaire baisse du nombre de
congés et éventuellement baisse du
salaire non je m'assure le sur le
travail je ne crois pas à la baisse de
jours de congés sur le travail je suis
favorable à l'annualisation et à
l'augmentation du temps de travail mais
n'ont pas décidé par la loi mais décidés
dans l'entreprise c'est à dire c'est là
que l'on définit le temps de travail au
plus près possible du carnet de
commandes
lorsque vous avez des moments où
l'économie va redémarrer il faut
travailler davantage
mais les heures travaillées doivent être
payés bien évidemment mais ça ça permet
aussi de faire des économies
d'une part ça permet d'augmenter le
salaire de ceux qui travaillent très
concrètement ça permet d'abaisser le
coût du travail et d'augmenter la
performance et la compétitivité une
salaire de ceux qui travaillent oui et
non parce que s'il a aujourd'hui quand
vous augmenter au delà des 35 heures
c'est payé en heures sup
oui défiscalisées qui puiserait mais
qu'on fêtait jeudi nicolas sarkozy à
l'époque non mais concrètement vous
faites pas d'heures supplémentaires
c'est ça la réalité c'est ce que vous
constatez que vous font l'employeur ne
va pas quoi est ce qu'il faut c'est
augmenter le temps de travail mais
encore une fois on le fait par le
dialogue social dans l'entreprise mais
on ne refait pas le x6m grenelle vous
savez cet alignement de quatre ou cinq
ministres avec les organisations
syndicales en face on sait ça finit à
l'échec
ça finira par des manifestations par des
blocages dans la rue on n'arrivera à
rien la corse et dans l'entreprise le
chef d'entreprise avec ses salariés
et là on a une vraie base de discussion
et de négociation et c'est comme ça que
je pense qu'on peut améliorer les choses
est-ce qu'il faut christian jacob
remettent les réformes sur le sur
l'établi retraite assurance chômage
bien sûr sur les alors sur les retraites
c'est mort avec ce gouvernement là tu es
comme ils n'ont fait aucune réforme vous
le disais tout à l'heure
cette réforme des retraites trois ans
pour rien les bourses strictement rien
elle existe elle est toujours dans
l'ordre il n'existe pas elle n'a rien
sénart
elle n'a ni queue ni tête personne ne
comprend rien personne n'est capable de
l'expliquer je vous mets au défi de
m'expliquer cette réforme n'a pas le
temps au mieux 2 heure et
vous y arriverez pas en deux heures
relève le défi la réforme des retraites
les simples elle est basée sur le temps
de travail
moi je pense qu'il faut travailler
davantage c'est une équation à trois
entrées soit vous vous baissez le vous
baisser le niveau des prestations des
retraites des retraités des pensions des
pensions soit vous baisser les pensions
choix vous augmenter les cotisations
soit vous allongez la durée du temps de
travail
moi je suis pour que l'on allonge la
durée de mal et on travaille très
clairement c'est clair ils qui sont
encore sur rd 107 grammes de la droite
intéressant il ya des plans de soutien
il ya des fonds de solidarité il ya 500
milliards
en additionnant appelé des carottes et
des choux comme l'a dit le président de
la république 500 milliards sur la table
est-ce que lorsqu'un air france par
exemple ce soir 7 milliards d'un prêt
garanti par l'état et en même temps
annonce entre huit et dix mille
suppressions de postes est ce que vous
dites c'est difficile d'avoir les deux
et de faire les deux je pense que ça
doit passer dans la négocier sur d'abord
moi je trouve qu'il est normal que
l'état d'en situer dans des contexte
aussi particulier que celui là
interviennent et accompagne carla c'est
unique et c'est une couche c'est une
bonne chose de le faire ça ne peut pas
être fait durablement et en face de cela
il faut aussi que les entreprises
s'adaptent à la situation du marché mais
ça c'est la négociation
normalement qui doit être mené à bercy
bercy peut pas découvrir aujourd'hui qui
a réussi un plan caché faut pas nous
raconter d'histoire donc le gouvernement
c'est sait pertinemment tout cela ça
fait partie de la négociation le chèque
de 2 7 milliards il n'est pas fait
contre rien sur les municipales qui
seront donc dans une semaine ce second
tour finalement des municipales après
que le premier tour aient eu lieu la
veille du confinement
ça devait être votre reconquête mais
vous êtes en train
peut-être de perdre marseille en tout
cas sur un fond de soupçons de triche
vous n'allez pas gagner paris sauf
énorme surprise vous pourriez gagner
lyon mais à quel prix une alliance
finalement avec la république en marche
c'est pas flambant quand même bah
écoutez d'abord on a renoué avec la
victoire
donc quand même rappeler les choses
telles qu'elles sont quand on regarde le
premier tour des élections municipales
si vous prenez les villes de plus de
mille habitants 56% des villes ont été
gagnés par les républicains et leur et
leurs alliés si vous prenez les villes
de plus de 30 mille habitants gagnés au
premier tour 70% ont été gagnés par les
républicains et leur allié donc quand
même après avoir est un échec cuisant
aux élections législatives ou non
seulement on est resté dans l'opposition
mandat / de notre nombre de députés les
européennes l'échec le plus cinglante on
n'est jamais reçu là on renoue avec la
victoire
très clairement ensuite on peut toujours
espérer qu'elle soit plus plus
importante
bon ceci étant écoutez moi je compte
tenu des résultats du premier tour je
reste tout à fait confiant sur le sur le
deuxième tour alors vous avez toujours
des surprises aux élections municipales
vous savez à paris
ce cas faire rachida dati ce
extraordinaire et il a été le coeur
battant de toute notre campagne du
premier tour partout en france point je
faisais beaucoup de déplacements partout
on me disait est alors rachida dati
comment ça se passe elle est un nouveau
visage de là il arrive de la cinquième
position dans les sondages d'octobre lé
deuxième aujourd'hui et le choix
aujourd'hui pour les parisiens il est
clair personne ne peut imaginer un
instant que madame hidalgo sera maire de
paris elle même d'ailleurs n'y crois pas
du tout personne n'y croit chez elle
donc le seul enjeu à paris que madame
angot quelques pas du musée jeanne
d'albret on dit quoi ya pas qu'à vous
que ça rit exemple vous remercie de ces
gentils c'est peut-être donc non
personne ne peut imaginer un instant que
madame busan soit soit maire de paris
elle même n'y crois pas donc l'enjeu il
est clair pour les parisiens soit on est
satisfaits de la gestion de madame
hidalgo on dit allez génial ont la
propriété de paris sur la sécurité sur
le logement
tout va pour le mieux dans le meilleur
des mondes à ce moment là on vote pour
madame hidalgo
mais sinon sinon la seule alternative
crédit sérieuses et rachida dati y ait
un vrai projet sur la sécurité sur le
logement et sur la propreté
christain jacob quand même vous êtes à
la tête de ce parti et on le voit il ya
des alliances étranges ou en tout cas
diverses
quand on regarde vraiment sur le terrain
a lyon c'est donc une alliance avec
gérard collomb à lille où les listes les
républicains appellent désormais à voter
pour martine aubry contre je le cite
les fous furieux écologistes et puis il
y a d'autres villes avec d'autres
alliances vous validez toutes ces
stratégies tout et on va remettre là
aussi je l'en place en termes de rapport
de force
deux cents soit si en france on a 2 173
villes de plus de 30 mille habitants il
y a eu un accord dans six villes sur 273
est dense et 6 3 où il ya eu des accords
avec des gens qui s'étaient présentés
sur des listes en marche au premier tour
en rue leur investiture retirer donc il
reste trois villes en france de plus de
30000 habitants sur 276 pour amener les
choses est ce qu'elle est ce qu'elles
sont dans des contextes d'ailleurs très
différents ce qui se passe à lyon
a lyon ce n'est pas un accord politique
c'est simplement que vous avez
l'ensemble des maires des élus de la
métropole de lyon qui disent écoutez
nous on ne veut pas d'une alliance
mélenchon plus les verts on veut pas de
l'extrême gauche et des verts et donc on
veut s'opposer à cela et se retrouver et
on veut se rassembler autour de françois
noël buffet qui était notre sang d'hier
les républicains avec la cocasse quand
on voit par l'un des républicains
appellent aujourd'hui à voter martine
aubry madame ces langages je vous
réponds sur lyon ensuite je veux bien
vous répondre sur ce joli joli l'on a
échoué c'est moi quand on échoue je vous
le dit notre lit ça l'a fait 7% quand on
échoue bon bah voilà on a échoué donc de
toute façon vous savez on ne passera
rien sur l'élection qui se fera à lille
parce que à 7% mais on a perdu
jacques à bâbord vous êtes un opposant
emmanuel macron la politique vous l'avez
démontré depuis et depuis trois quarts
d'heure fois qu'on peut lire et en même
temps on voit votre parti qui est
parfois celle des accords pas vous en a
parlé de lyon mais dans d'autres villes
aussi avec la république en marche est
ce que maintenant quand il faut gagner
mais tous les moyens sont bons
non je vous rappelle 2 173 villes de
plus de 30 mille habitants civils où il
ya eu un accord et dans sur ses six dans
trois ou la république en marche à
retirer l'investiture dont on parle de
trois villes sur 273 2 mai et décédé
ville emblématique oui mais mais lyon je
vous expliquer comment ça serait lyon
c'est pas un accord politique
j'ai jamais rien négocié et personne n'a
jamais rien négocié avec les
représentants avec le parti de la
république en marche simplement vous
avez des élus locaux qui disent écoutez
nous on ne veut pas de cette alliance de
l'extrême gauche et des verts
voilà ce qui se passe et se rassemblent
autour du candidat qui leur semble le
meilleur est le candidat qui leur semble
le meilleur
est-ce qu'ils aient ou du peu mais c'est
notre candidat alors c'est françois noël
buffet jacob je vous je vous emmène au
havre je veux dire vous n'avez rien au
fait monsieur je vous incite à l'eau
havre vous êtes habitants du havre je
préfère est à provins oui mais vous êtes
habitants du à vous voir et pour qui
quand même vous votez pour edouard
philippe ou pour jean-paul lecoq le
candidat communiste a coûté au premier
tour je n'aurais de toute façon pas voté
pour edouard philippe puisqu'on avait la
chance d'avoir une liste divers droite
ça ou moins très clair non mais là sur
le sur le deuxième tour et coûté si
j'étais habitants rendu à ce que je ne
suis pas bon il est certain que je
choisirai pas l'extrême gauche
d'accord vous voteriez pour y voir un
livre je choisirais pas besoin de gauche
et comme en règle générale oui j'ai dit
oui j'ai du mal parce que il fait partie
des gens qui ont travaillé leur famille
politique
et honnêtement la politique économique
est conduite depuis trois ans est
catastrophique
elle s'est fait dans la poursuite de ce
qui a été fait par françois hollande
donc non je n'ai pas d'admiration pour
la politique conduite par edouard
philippe
après à titre personnel c'est quelqu'un
que je connais que je peux apprécier
humainement mais honnêtement je n'ai
aucune affinité
mais dans la politique qui conduirait
mais c'était vraiment vous nous avez été
dans une situation du pire oui mais
c'est intéressant parce que s'il devait
quitter matignon a coûté à vendre nos
machines et communistes vous avez du
chemin va bien sûr mais vous auriez pas
retenir mais vous vous abstenez pas donc
c'est intéressant christian jacob
si edouard philippe devait quitter
matignon est ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut rentrer à la maison
est ce que il a des choses à faire avec
vous à droite avec nous non mais il a
sans doute des choses à faire rue pour
lui poser la question avec vous non
d'ailleurs
non mais je crois qu'il a beaucoup de au
bidon qu'il arrivera à s'occuper je les
fais confiance
il n'a pas sa place comme comme dit
david du camp à la maison c'est à dire
and what men on n'est pas dans du
marchandage nous ce qui nous intéresse
c'est de bâtir c'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire de bâtir un projet pour
la france
on vient de lancer un gros travail de
fond plus de 80 forum que nous avons
réuni 180 réunions de groupes de travail
qui se sont tenus là depuis quatre mois
on en train de bâtir ce projet on vient
de travailler pendant une journée
complète un séminaire avec tous les
dirigeants des républicains qui ont
travaillé qui ont travaillé ensemble
on prépare notre congrès des idées on
n'est pas là sur telle ou telle débauche
jaunâtre
mais tout de même quand même il n'y a
pas de leader absolu chez vous savez on
peut pas dire qu'en ce moment il ya un
leader clair il est où il est où
françois baroin par exemple pour mener
2022 je sais que ça fait partie de vos
espoirs il est où là aujourd'hui la
droite elle est là où elle est en train
de se reconstruire il ya un temps pour
chaque chose
on a ce talent à droite de savoir
organiser des batailles de personnes de
se taper dessus de se fracturer
lorsqu'on est génial on est même les
champions du monde dans ce domaine
propre et bien pour une fois on essaye
de prendre les choses autrement et de
travailler sur le fond de travailler sur
les idées et c'est ce que j'ai voulu
faire depuis un an et c'est ce qu'on est
en train de faire et on va travailler
sur les idées et quand tu vas venir le
problème en de l'incarnation et bien à
ce moment là croyez-moi quand le y aura
il y aura quelqu'un nous allons incarner
ça n'est pas le temps de l'incarnation
et c'est le temps wim cei quand on a
pris depuis huit ans on a perdu toutes
les élections nationales tout n'a pas
gagné une
on a tout perdu et ça va passer un peu
d'un peu de modestie un peu d'humilité
retournons sur le terrain travaillons
sur le fond et après croyez moi il y
aura quelqu'un pour incarner notre
projet ne vous faites ça que ça se
passera commande ailleurs ce choix de
l'incarnation il ya dans les statuts du
parti
les primaires existe toujours peut-être
qu'il pourra se faire naturellement le
choix de la carnation envers on faisait
ça n'est pas le sujet du moment mais
c'est souvent jeunes et vous espérez
avoir à vous passer de primaires pour
leur intelligence et moi j'ai toujours
été à nous pose en faire moins de bruit
mer dont je vais pas changer
mais au delà c'est de la chance que je
souhaite c'est qu'on travaille sur le
fond c'est si quand on perd toutes les
élections nationales pendant huit ans
faut quand même se poser quelques
questions et arrêter d'être persuadé
d'avoir la réponse à tout est de savoir
tout sur tout donc un peu de modestie
encore est ce que rachida dati pour être
le futur visage
on peut écouter rachida dati un visage
qui a animé toute la vie elle était le
coeur battant du premier tour des
municipales au rush c'est quand même un
autre débat les régionales et révèle et
original qui serait repoussée après 2022
une combine bonne idée vu ce qui se
passe vraiment là bas vous l'avez dit
vous-même on est dans la combine
les led démocratie c'est
les élections je n'ai pas senti mais les
élections c'est un rendez vous enfin
c'est l'organisation de la démocratie le
rendez vous entre entre un homme une
liste et le peuple on ne les cales pas
en fonction de l'opportunité
politicienne du président de la
république c'est ça n'est pas monsieur
macron qui décident en fonction des
opportunités des dates des élections
et pourquoi ne repousserait palais
présidentiel tant qu'on y est après tout
il pourrait nous expliquer que du fait
du coc vite quand même il n'a pas pu
finir son quinquennat comme il le
souhaitait il a quand même besoin d'un
nom plus de retour dans le ridicule
des élections sont prévues au mois de
mars doivent se tenir à l'échéance
prévue
christian jacob deux questions à la fois
internationale mais qui nous préoccupe
et qui nous et qui nous touchent d'abord
l'une sur ce qui s'est passé cette nuit
en angleterre une attaque au couteau
trois morts d'après le parquet
britannique
il s'agit d'une attaque de nature
terroriste
on l'apprend à l'instant c'est le sait
le retour du terrorisme après cette
parenthèse qui avaient tous figés y
compris ces questions là écoutez on doit
être le risque est permanent on le sait
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que j'avais
cette défense de leurs avec peut-être
beaucoup de passion sur nos forces de
sécurité mais on voit bien que le risque
il est permanent en europe et ailleurs
d'ailleurs au delà des frontières
européennes
et ce qui vient de se passer en
angleterre nous touche parce que parce
que la france a été touchée l'angleterre
elle était vous permettait aussi d'avoir
moment de compassion à la fois pour nous
nos amis britanniques et pour les
familles qui vont être en deuil et suite
à un acte terroriste ce qui montre
combien la vigilance doit être
importante et combien on doit avoir
aussi le respect de nos forces de
sécurité
un mot quand même sur ce qui se passe
aussi aux états unis la reprise de la
campagne avec un meeting de donald trump
hier soir question finalement presque
assez provocante mais est ce que ce
serait mieux pour le monde que donald
trump ne soit pas réélu je laisserai
c'est votre position non je pas de
position sur la position énoncée
mais c'est aux américains de choisir
leur président mais arrêtons d'être les
français donneurs de leçons par tour a
décidé du choix du président
des états unis là aussi un peu de mots
des lendemains choisir tout simplement
la douceur du moment que c'est pas lui
et qu'ils continuent ont choisi ça a un
impact quand même évident sur ce qui se
passe en europe mais ce qui est évident
c'est que on a on a eu depuis barack
obama un retrait des états unis sur la
scène internationale et ce qui nous a
d'ailleurs ce qui n'a pas été sans nous
mettre en difficulté
et ça ne date pas de 30 sa date de
barack obama et peut-être même un peu un
peu avant et donc aujourd'hui la
personnalité de trump clivante
provocante que comme elle est bien
évidemment il nous choque ou plus haut
point parce que ça n'est pas notre mode
de fonctionnement et donc que quand on
est habitué à un vieux pays
pour paraphraser dominique de villepin
comme le nôtre une vieille démocratie
comme que comme la nôtre bon on est
choqué par cette attitude
mais force est de constater que au moins
il ya quatre ans elle a convenu aux
américains donc etc en effet l'élection
ne se passe là bas on vous a emmené au
havre en vous demandant pour lequel vous
feriez si vous étés si vous étiez
habitants du havre autant ne vous
demande pas pour qui vous vous feriez si
vous étiez américain merci christian
jacob d'abord été avec nous dans bfm
politique rappelle donc que vous êtes
bien sûr le président du parti les
républicains merci à david merci pauline
merci à être riche devrions dans un
instant l'actualité continue sur bfm tv
vous avez rendez vous avec philippe
godin et dominique rizet pour aperçue
vivante et pour ma part